you can finally experience destiny 2 on
PC with the beta that hit our gaming
rigs but do you know how your system's
gonna handle it
establish fans of the franchise and
those who wanted the game to come to PC
should be hyped up the game runs
extremely well even on Modest systems
I'm running an Intel Core i5 35 70 K CPU
an MSI GTX 970 slightly overclocked and
8 gigabytes of ddr3 RAM which falls
pretty much in line with what Bungie and
Activision States as the recommended
system specs for destiny 2 but what does
that translate to what could we actually
get out of these specs but before we
move on make sure you're subscribed to
GameSpot for more game tech first let's
take a look at our options in the
graphics menu Bungie didn't skimp out on
the PC version as promised we have the
option for an uncapped framerate there's
also an option to lock it at 60 FPS or
even 30 FPS but there really isn't any
reason to do this one of the most
important and sometimes overlooked
options and shooters is field of view or
FOV it's essentially how wide your
viewing angle is of the game environment
the higher it is the more you can see in
your peripheral vision it's a
competitive advantage since you'll see
more of what's going on at any given
moment so crank that coveted fov slider
up somewhere between 95 and 105 though
personally I go with the max at 105 now
let's dig into actual visual effects to
get rid of jaggies we effectively have 4
anti-aliasing options FXAA SMA a MSAA
and super sampling fxaa tends to make
the game look a little too blurry so I'd
opt for SMA since it strikes a nice
balance between performance and quality
while the better-looking MSA 8ax my
machine too much with all our settings
cranked up at 1080p our quick little
test in the opening area showed a frame
rate around the high 60s to the high 70s
with SMA 8 with msaa the frame rate
dipped around the low to mid 40s it's
not worth the 30 or so FPS trade-off
with my modest system but note that this
is still a beta and Bungie said that
MSAA is still being optimized resolution
scale is synonymous with super sampling
you force your machine to produce a
higher resolution image and downscale it
to fit your displays proper resolution
it's the most effective form of
anti-aliasing but it's also the most
demanding at 133 percent
essentially 1440p the framerate dipped
to about the mid-40s
another big hitter in the graphic
settings is ambient occlusion which is a
process of darkening objects that should
be blocked by light sources creating a
sort of fake shadow that adds richness
and depth to the scene there are two
options HD AO and 3d as for performance
with everything maxed out including MSAA
the difference between HD AO and 3d was
around 5 frames per second in the same
test scene
run clear as to exactly what the 3d
setting is but if I had to guess it's
something similar to the advance of VX
AO
I saw a few more objects in the game
rolled with better shadowing but I felt
I had to really look hard for it so I
opted for the extra fps with HD AO when
we turn ambient occlusion completely off
we got three to five extra fps but the
overall image looked flatter so I find
HD AO worth it anisotropic filtering is
labeled as texture and I sought repeat
this setting cleans up the quality of
textures off in the distance and
surfaces that are seen at an oblique
angle it's one of the more visually
impactful effects that doesn't ask too
much from your hardware
I'd suggest cranking this up to 16 X
since the performance hit if any is
negligible it's like a free bump
individual quality many of the other
settings are quite self-explanatory such
as quality of textures shadows or the
distance at which certain things like
character models and foliage keep their
quality chromatic aberration and film
grain don't really have a performance
impact and are more about personal
preference when it was all set and done
I settled with 1080 P SMA a HD AO 16 x
texture filtering and all the quality
settings set to the highest through my
several hours in multiplayer matches the
game ranked consistently above 60 frames
per second bouncing between the mid 70s
to the mid 90s only in the most frantic
moments did I notice the framerate dip
to the high 50s but that's negligible
you shouldn't expect to run the game at
4k at the recommended specs but we gave
it a shot anyway you turn off
anti-aliasing use HD AO turn all the
quality settings to high but shadows to
medium the results were between the mid
20s to the mid 30s which is undesirable
given that it's a disadvantage for a
competitive PC game where everyone else
is likely getting upwards of 60 frames
per second 4k is reserved for those
equipped with the GTX 970 or an Rx Vega
56 at the very release but you probably
want a GTX 1080 1080 Ti or arts Vega 64
new 4k comfortably overall the pc
version of destiny 2 is shaping up to be
a great version of the game and runs
fast with high graphics settings even on
modest hardware on top of that Bungie is
giving us an uncapped frame rate and fov
slider in even a built in FPS counter
keep in mind that this is still a beta
options we see here could change by the
time of the final release and future
drivers and updates can improve
performance metrics there's so much more
I could talk about with graphics
settings alone but I want to throw the
discussion to you are you excited for
destiny to which platform will you be
playing on if you want a deeper dive
into the options we talked about here
check out our explainer videos on PC
graphics settings like anti-aliasing or
ambient occlusion subscribe for more
stuff like this and like this video if
you found it insightful thanks for
watching we'll see you next time